[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
today we have the pleasure of sitting
down with Steve Hoffman hello how are
you great to be here yeah they have for
coming on the show
my pleasure beautiful studio thank you
thank you beautiful mind to share with
the audience I hope so
yeah let's do this so Steve is the CEO
of founders space he is also a partner
at founders VC and the author of make
elephants fly yes so we are going to be
unpacking innovation the process of
innovation why it's so important we'll
be talking about you know your work the
last six years now doing this helping
entrepreneurs around the world yes yeah
like why I help entrepreneurs or what
yeah they need a lot of help that sir
I've been an entrepreneur I screwed up a
few times you know had my share of
troubles I know how hard it is to do
anything new right to do anything on
your own being an entrepreneur I mean
everybody's an entrepreneur like if
you're if you want to do something new
if you want to start a charity if you
want to start a rock band if you want to
be an artist if you want to you know be
the next Jeff Bezos you're an
entrepreneur you're out there a building
you're you know you have to build your
own organization you have to have a goal
you have to achieve it it's all
entrepreneurship yeah and I think
sometimes we get lost in the cult the
culture and the the social fabric to
such a point where we don't even realize
when we're when the idea comes up and
when we have the potential to bring it
to life but then it kind of gets clouded
by the cult the cultural forces and then
it's really difficult to take that that
step a lot of the time it's money is
like this first thing is like I don't
want to feel unsafe I don't want to take
a big risk with starting that idea what
if I fail
yeah those are all you know who wants to
quit their job and have no money and
invest it all in some crazy idea that
you don't even know will work and most
likely won't work the only thing that
you have to believe it works to even
make that leap it's a very tough
decision for people you know most people
don't do it the majority of people have
kind of their dreams of what they could
do you know open a yogurt shop or all
you know I'll do my own tech startup or
all you know do this big charity or what
but they never actually do it yeah and
that's that's that's the quote about how
the richest place in the world is the
graveyard because it's where all the
ideas never gone yeah they never get
active but when and but when you do it
then you you usually need help even if
you're like super experienced sometimes
you just need that a lot of what I do is
just that to be there to talk through
the problems with them you know the
support the mental support because it I
will tell you even the smartest people
in the world you know the Elon Musk's of
the world they screw up all the time yes
you know we saw it like just the other
week Elon Musk's entire automated
production line didn't work right and
now Tesla's you know is in serious
financial trouble you know their stock
is plummeting the cars aren't being
produced this is a guy that you know
entrepreneurs around the world admire as
kind of like God you know over automated
okay he overawed it to all of us make
mistakes right and he's like he had to
admit I totally screwed up I like had
machines doing everything and they're
things that people do better you know
machines still aren't there yet yeah
exactly
even then Elon needs to consult other
people to figure out how do I get the
right humans into the positions on
assembly and then use then also use the
machines in symbiosis but then I'm sure
he had its own hubris right he's a man
of technology he wanted to have that he
wanted to tell everybody I had the fully
automated car production line like
nobody's ever done you can over stretch
right Ikaros right
he's going to Mars but you know you can
go to the Sun and burn up along the way
yeah and and I think another key about
this taking that leap of faith with
entrepreneurship is also that it becomes
this best decision you've ever made in
your life down the line you got to get
over your one your to your three turn
money make money make impact
self-sustained sustain other people
build a family around you of people that
care about the project and once you
really get there after a couple years it
just the feeling is just there's nothing
else like in the world it's amazing but
you're talking about a small minority so
you're talking like ninety percent fail
under like 95 percent realistically it's
so of you know from the idea stage right
it depends what stage you measure so if
you look at the venture stage we're the
big guys who are supposed to pick the
winners come in with the big money it's
still like a 70% failure rate you know
when you're actually getting venture
funding so when you're talking the idea
stage it's much higher right it's it's a
lot and you know I see it so most of we
never hear about them you know person
will start an idea and it dies I start
an idea and it dies it's like how many
times have you done that in your life
already a couple of ideas that I started
and just you know there's one thing to
have an idea another thing to make it a
reality
yeah there are a lot of different parts
to that idea and any one of them doesn't
work and the idea doesn't work yeah yeah
so a lot of entrepreneurs like you're
talking like when you made it it feels
great but how do you feel great when you
don't make it which is most people like
yeah how do you feel great and how do
you get a lot out of the process yeah
and that's a journey yeah and that's a
lot of what I put into my book you know
make elephants fly it's a lot of what I
do when I travel around the world
working with entrepreneurs because I've
been there right like you right I've
done stuff and I haven't always
succeeded so I know how difficult it can
be and I can total and I'm a dreamer
right so I'm always coming up with ideas
so I can completely relate to people and
then I can work with them to hopefully
maximize never guarantee their chance of
getting where they want to go in the
long run and
may not even be on the current path
there are a lot of times the whole
process is switching paths switching
again switching again until you finally
kind of find something where you're you
complete for it exactly yeah it almost
seems like it's inevitable that you end
up switching paths and then for the band
the breakthrough because there's so many
ideas that want us to go through and so
much of that entrepreneurial process
that is different to cross those things
but also similar to where you've learned
a lot that way you're not repeating the
same mistakes and hopefully you have
good mentors around you other people
that can help guide you you bring this
up I think it's really important is that
source of mentorship and emotional
support along the journey because that
seems to be I mean imagine being there
by yourself it may be one other person
if and and you're really really gunning
at wearing 12 different hats yeah and
they're draining your bank account you
may have borrowed money from family or
friends and added stresses right yeah
and then you're hitting obstacles and
people who tell you no it won't work it
won't work
it will you think like your own that
voice in the back of your head the
doubter voice right and it's really hard
and that's why having that support the
emotional support is as important as or
maybe more important than the financial
support yeah and and then also this
analytical support as well really so
it's like experienced people exactly the
they can come in and they can see the
way the the way that you were once
trying to be efficient with the delivery
of their product or the manufacturing
their product and they might be able to
just give you a piece of advice that
could increase your efficiencies in one
of those areas by so much by so much or
make a relationship like look let me
introduce you to so-and-so they're like
I know you're having manufacturing
problems but this person deals with it
all the time like the factories in China
aren't producing your product the way
you want they keep screwing up well this
person will get you with a factory that
does it and they'll manage the whole
process there are people like that that
an entrepreneur wouldn't even know like
they just you know randomly pick
somebody to partner with and
may not be the right partner yeah we're
their own experience you know just you
know when I hit this obstacle you know I
hit a similar obstacle this is what I
did you know this is how I got around
that obstacle do we do we have a shared
wisdoms of entrepreneurship yet like a
fundamental principles what we have kind
of like well yeah well you know we have
a lot of books right so my book is one
piece of it being an entrepreneur is
very complex right there's many
different elements to being an
entrepreneur and different authors have
different perspectives and different
experiences you know I wrote my book
based on you know doing three venture
funded startups doing teaching hundreds
of startups around the world that's my
experience there are other great people
who will give you their experience like
their more focus maybe on marketing or
our growth hacking or sales there are
all these different elements you know
entrepreneurship isn't one thing it's
all these different disciplines and so
what I tell every entrepreneur is read
as much as possible like just like
immerse yourself in books and then
because what you're doing is you're
getting the distillation of the best
ideas of super experienced people even
if you had those people as mentors it
would be a different type of help
because the good thing about mentoring
vers books so books if you want the
knowledge the core knowledge there's no
better way to get it like if I meet you
you're not gonna brain dump all your
knowledge on me that would just be crazy
you know you're just not gonna do it you
know sometimes we do try yeah yeah but
that would just be overload right you
would say go watch my videos or go read
my book right that's where it all is
somebody out but when you're mentoring
it's more about specific addressing
specific problems that you have right
now you know and the book is about
building the foundations of all the
knowledge that you can draw upon when
making decisions yeah yeah it's a good
way to put it so and okay
so let's break let's break down some of
the fundamentals and the foundation
because I think the this this source of
creativity yes Ron what is creativity
right what
when we talk about the idea what is what
is one of the ways that you talk about
the idea you say the idea has you right
yes you are that you have the
responsibility to the idea it's not
necessarily your idea that's where we
get lost in ego when we come up with a
brilliant idea we think it's ours but we
fail to realize it's no you're just
privy to this idea it's your
responsibility to let it manifest or or
give it to someone else but don't ever
get lost and believing you're so
wonderful you came up with this that ID
is exactly what I tell my entrepreneurs
awesome so I tell them many of the most
successful companies and people in the
world it wasn't their idea like they you
know Elon Musk we're just talking about
him he didn't start Tesla like that
wasn't his company he was an early
investor you know Travis a Callen ik
right he didn't start over that wasn't
his idea he was in ER he got all the
credit right but it wasn't even his idea
most of the people up there you know
Microsoft you know with Microsoft
Windows that wasn't his idea he borrowed
it from Apple it wasn't Steve Jobs idea
he borrowed it from Xerox so it doesn't
matter whose idea it is it's how you
execute on it it's what you do with that
idea and as you were saying sometimes
you aren't the best person to do that
you know you aren't the best person to
take your idea to the next level you
need to bring those people either on
your team or handoff your idea so it can
actually have a life is that it open you
know then people think they're stealing
an idea you know it gets real
complicated you know people who are
gonna keep their idea doesn't we all
steal ideas it's like stealing ideas is
how we evolved as a civilization like if
we did not take each other's ideas and
open them we would still be living in
case yeah so I say I see if people talk
about oh I'm worried about stealing
ideas I was like there's a million ideas
out there people are still yours and
you'll still there mm-hmm all that
matters is what you do and do it yeah
just go out and do something you don't
worry about in fact it's a gift to the
world you know let's do a peek into
history I think this is important to do
when you're a tribe and you see that
another tribe has figured out how to do
something by farming or weapons and or
whatever it is right you know navigation
you're gonna copy them yeah if you don't
shame on you right yeah yeah your tribe
is gonna fall behind yeah so the entire
world is a giant Xerox machine right
we're copying everything and and then
we're improving upon yeah incrementally
improving upon everything everything out
there Facebook was a copy of MySpace and
Friendster and you know you go on backs
all of these things are copies of you
can always find where they copy every
great artist is a copy of previous
artists influenced by them taking it in
a slightly new direction putting their
own stamp on it and so what we're all
doing I'm copying every day that's why
that's why till you read so much absorb
knowledge go to museums
meet super interesting people have
amazing conversations because that gives
you all the raw material to be creative
you can you the it never comes from
within you like it doesn't it's a
combination of the structure of your
mind
and all the different external inputs
and how you recombine it yeah you know
yeah you're the combination machine do
that is creativity like you're the
machine that puts it all together in a
slightly different way than somebody
else or see something or I think such a
huge key of what you just said was that
the out wherever you focus your outside
attention your attention on the outside
world is how your mind will be shaped
and then that's where your creative
ideas will come from so if we're
spending a lot of our time on just
barely surviving and meeting
physiological needs we probably don't
have that much time to try and be
creative but soon and that's why a lot
of great works of art weren't created in
our early history up in our first you
know couple hundred thousand years it
was real it's all in the past you know
few thousand years where we had the
resources the means and most importantly
the time yeah yeah if you're living
hand-to-mouth
hand to mouth you hand them out
do not have a lot of time right you're
just like get food get food survived and
yeah oh that's a that's a good yeah
that's a good way to put people to
describe the process of not having the
ability to have time to be creative
hand-to-mouth yeah and a lot of people
are doing that now and unfortunately you
know the gig economy and things like
that make it difficult because you're
getting paid not enough money so in it
so you have to work on the time and with
the gig economy it's like there is no
there the labor laws don't really apply
so you might be working three different
gigs you know driving uber delivering
pizza you know working in a restaurant
just to get enough money to survive it
doesn't leave you the time to actually
really use your mind for what it was for
all the whole potential it hassles yeah
it and it's it also seems that that is
so applicable to children as well
because they have all of this beautiful
creative potential at such a young age
and then it's like here's the iPad and
then it's here's mom and dad make money
they're gone for 12 hours a day because
they have to cry to the clerk and you
know there's no parental guidance to
creativity there and then the there's
this season we're lacking on the
inspiring creativity along this way
totally and it gets even worse because
parents today even the most educated and
especially the most ambitious parents
will over program their kids you know
you're going to piano lessons now then
soccer then you have homework then you
have this then you have that and the
kids have no free time right so they
have no time to make their own decisions
oh you're playing piano you're being
creative no I'm just doing what my
parents told me and I'm you know just
studying the lessons you know that's not
creativity creativity is when you have
the time to sit there and doodle the
sitter and bang away on the piano
without practicing a lesson yeah thank
you to sit there in a playground and
make up your own games that you're gonna
play like with your friends instead of
playing games to where the rules are
already made yes being creative about
making your own rules
yeah not about following the rules or
doing what other people tell you and you
need time
boom let's timestamp that right there
that's so good
being creatives making your own damn
rules it is yeah and that's and that's
what we got to encourage people to do
right because our biggest breakthroughs
our best ideas everything comes from
that comes from actually you know
sitting around when you're not checking
your phone and responding to you know
Facebook or all these things you know
you're I can when you're in the shower
when you have a downtime don't know why
they're called shower thoughts right
it's not because the shower isn't magic
it's because it's like one of the only
safe harbors where you just don't that
your phone is a gold put electric
devices inside of showers please you do
the last safe space do not then then
that goes away right or in the middle of
the night when you're like lying in bed
you can't sleep those are other good
times for ideas yeah in putting the you
know I'm hoping you know we have so many
more people on this planet now right so
many more Minds that work we're much
better educated we have much better
tools you know the average education
look has so much higher so much we have
so much more potential now than ever
before in history uh to be creative to
do novel things to change the world for
the better
um the only thing we're lacking
unfortunately is time okay I have a
question along the way it's really a
slight tangent but it's very important I
think to address this so time is the
biggest thing we're all more educated
than we've been in the past which is
great but the amount of time that we
like to actually be creative is a veces
that we need to change so are you in
favor of universal basic income to
enable people to have time well I'm in
favor of it for a lot of reasons I'm in
favor of it because I think you know in
a rich economy nobody should be homeless
on the street absolutely I mean
absolutely not and other people are
homeless because of drug addiction or
mental illness we should have some
facilities to help them second I'm in
favor because as a technologist I see um
we're gonna have massive job loss I mean
it's coming it's like it it doesn't
matter
yes technology creates more jobs and
there will be many new jobs that you
cannot imagine except but in the process
of transition people are gonna get left
behind yes and we've gotta have this for
those people a third if it can give
people more time to be creative that's
great yeah I think all of those are good
I think a bigger problem when we talk
about time to be creative is the bigger
danger is is not even not having enough
money to do it it's because I know many
people have lots of money who have no
time to be creative it's that we program
ourselves up now because our devices are
constantly bombarding us with very
tantalizing yeah alluring
information and and entertainment and
our friends contacting us that we are
always having to respond to yeah and I
personally in order to make more time to
be creative and more time to feel sane I
turned off all my notifications I have
no notifications on my phone messages
come in but they don't pop up
they don't distract me so I will still
check Facebook I'll still check my email
all these different things but I'll do
it on my schedule yeah and that way when
I'm working every few seconds I'm not
getting dragged away because of course
in order to be creative you need
uninterrupted time vision it has to be
long enough so you know the flow so you
can get into the flow and start thinking
deeply and the creativity and you can
never get into flow if you have a
constant beeps and person you know in
little little red circles with numbers
in them that like are irresistible candy
to us adults right I have to I have to
eat it you know lottery machine yeah
these uninterrupted blocks of time for
flow yeah and so like my book is about
innovation and and this is like a core
piece of being innovative right just
structuring your life so you have enough
time yeah actually yeah think beyond
your your normal constraints and put you
in favor of universal basic income but
do you know exactly how you want to
provide that do you think how it should
be provided to know there's a lot of
different experiments going on you know
in the Nordic countries things like that
well I don't personally haven't spent
the time to research I mean there are
many different ways to there are yeah
yeah and I'm not an expert on that but
the core concept yeah absolutely
cool we need to figure this out and we
need to figure it out in a way that
people you know I'm a personal believer
you know everybody says a welfare will
make you fat and lazy you know or
Universal income would make you fat and
lazy but anybody who's driven to do
something will do it regardless like I
don't need the money
from what I'm doing but I'm doing it and
I'm working harder than I ever have in
my life yeah the money is not my driving
purpose it doesn't it's it's an
afterthought it's nice to have but most
people who want to be a scientist a
musician or artist even a businessperson
do you think a Bill Gates needs more
money why is he working so hard on this
charities done right well that's he's
clearly not a case but you look at most
of the billionaires in the world they
work like crazy right they work like all
the time together they don't need the
money besides I'm not why they became
successful men in their life from so the
universal basic income won't stop those
people what we need to do is encourage
people you know like through your show
and other means to actually get off
their butts out of these chairs right
and do something yes their lives and
show them most people don't do something
not because they don't want to because
they don't think it's possible they
don't think they can't you so it's not
the money it's not how much money they
have or how little money or they just
don't believe they can do it and they've
been told you know time and again and
verbally but a lot of times through
their own failures and experience yeah
you don't got what it takes you know
you're lucky to just be getting bought
and they eventually accept it which is
the tragedy the loss of their potential
you know yeah and that's what that's
what like my mission is and I think your
mission in different ways we've
manifested it in different ways but it's
to get out so hiring people to build the
future
it's to tell them you have all this
potential yes you might have failed but
that has no reflection on what you can
to do it only has reflection on what you
did wrong or what life which is so
random and chaotic and unpredictable in
the world fail all the time we failed
and then but the people who actually end
up doing something just get back up like
they're not flat on their back they feel
horrible
they have self-doubt and they get back
up and they're going again you know
they're figuring some other path out
this show is so about that yeah to
inspire people to build the future
across all these different industries
and why do it that self-actualization is
unprecedented there's nothing that
brings you more happiness to life than
unleashing your potential from within
you into the world and knowing that the
sources that you're looking at at the
external world are shaping your mind in
a very beautiful way that whole process
is so incredible and to inspire other
children to have that it's definitely a
huge premise of both of us and across
the world we're not just carrying about
just the United States we care about
everybody in the world because there's
so much different creative potential
across the different cultures in the
world all right I want to before we get
back to the foundation because I think
dual well unpack that a little bit more
along the way we talked about the
significance of impact over money yes
and let's unpack that more because we
talked about this on the show so much is
that it feels like so much better and
you know teal wrote about it in zero to
one as well but the less a CEO gets paid
the better the company does and it's
Lizzy keep as close to like zero dollars
in your bank account have that fire
under your ass yet if all the money you
make and pour it back into the business
those are the entrepreneurs we love
right yeah because they they believe so
much in their idea that the the money
they have it doesn't matter they're it's
just a tool for them to get where they
need to go and I will tell you
of money you know I've my whole theory
about money
the reason we value money so much
there's one reason it's not because of
what we can buy with it because most of
us if we have enough food and if we have
a comfortable place to live we can think
oh yes we is it money is time no okay my
theory money is social status so human
beings we are tribal creatures we are
group animals right we go in a herd
right that's how we survived that's how
we evolved in that environment what we
matters to us most is our position
within our group we want to feel good
about our position right and that
goodness can be attained through lots of
different ways it can be a change by
helping other people like really
genuinely unless you're Psychopaths
right you you tend to feel good when you
help somebody right that's built into us
you tend to feel good when you help the
group really good and especially good
when the group recognizes that you help
them unfortunately this construct of
money has been conflated with status
right so our society here in the United
States especially but all around the
world because I travel you know I work
you know in dozens of countries all
around the world we tend to think of
rich people as having achieved somebody
and we Accord them a higher status you
know if you have money you have done so
much more than if you have not it and
that is why they work so hard to get
more money they could never have enough
money because they feel like oh I'm
always competing with the richer guy
above me in these billionaires even if
they're not philanthropic even if
they're not really good people they
still have that drive to be recognized
by the world for what they do
mm-hmm so part of like what your show is
doing and part of what you know like I
talked about and I think we need more of
in this society are people saying that
money in like you just said is not
status right it's what you do with the
money that
it's what you what you do with your life
that counts if we should be judging
people on their actions in their true
contributions yeah not just their bank
account yeah and I you know I hate it
like when they have the the Forbes 100
richest people and all this stuff you
know and all these different magazines
and stuff are always writing about the
rich they're not talking about what
these people did I want to see the 100
most amazing people who did the most
amazing things even if you never earned
a dollar in your life that's what I care
about not that the the richest people in
the world that's the wrong message and
we keep sending that message we send it
through our commercials you know buy
this expensive car you know do this all
these things you know go on these
vacations because that defines who you
are that doesn't like what you said
people throughout history you know they
do there was hundreds of hundreds of
thousands of years where money didn't
exist right money didn't exist so money
is just a proxy for our accomplishments
in life in those hundreds of thousands
of years we evolved through what we did
not through money right now money is
taken over as that and I think that's
one of the great weaknesses of our
culture right now and something we could
fix so well said Steve there's a lot of
people that are wealthy that don't want
to hear these things they want you to
think they're intelligent because
they're wealthy and that's problematic I
know people that are terribly dumb and
have lots of money and spend it on
ridiculous things and themselves and
they they think they think they're smart
too they'll they'll have conversation
with you and argue their silly ideas and
it's totally it's totally I meet rich
people all the time
huge I mean billionaires quite often all
around the world and very you know in
the heads of state and all this stuff
which is another proxy you know
political power mom but I meet them all
the time in their very insecure they're
like they're like you think you would be
secure like with God but they kind of
know like inside you know a lot of what
a lot of times they get
through politics right the you know get
in a position get the head of a bank you
know through political maneuverings or
they made money I know some very wealthy
people who just happen to have the right
thing at the right time
they weren't brilliant but they were at
the right place at the right time and
some of them there's different types of
intelligence to some people are very
smart with like financial things but
they're very stupid when it comes to
like their life decisions but they wind
up with a lot of money end up being
incredibly unhappy wasting the money you
know their marriage falls apart they
have no relationship with their kids and
all these things you have to laugh it's
you know it's terribly sad I mean it's
sad I can't be sad about it it's
hilarious wealthy wealthy miserable
people I think is the most funniest
thing it's it's funny in it's tragic
it's tragic because they think that they
they want to believe like all of us want
to but all of us want to feel whether
were rich or poor or somewhere in the
middle we want to feel our life means
something we want to feel what we're
doing has real value and a lot of them
thought when they became very wealthy
that that would fulfill them and then
they find out they get there and it's
it's you know it's kind of a hollow
promise and so for all of us how do we
get to the you know they've done many
psychological studies and the one thing
that consistently fulfills people the
most is your relationships with other
people and it comes back to what I said
my theory of the tribe right it was all
about the relationships it was about how
you interact the quality of those
relationships what it means within the
context of your group that is the one
thing that will consistently fulfill you
and you can have that those
relationships at any wealth level you
can it's so funny that what you
described with the with the Forbes 100
most impactful people yes that that is
kind of what we're doing with this great
with this portrait book yeah everybody
that gets photographed for the book is
you know doing a making good math good
solid impact across different industries
in the world
and so to have a to have kind of a
starting point in that world of trying
to highlight these impactful people not
richest to people is I'm really happy
that you know we're even in the process
of really embodying that and
implementing it and who [ __ ] Forbes it
doesn't need it
Forbes oh it's simulation simulation
factorable people and know there's so
many volumes you know we just this first
volume will be released in just a couple
months of the book and they'll be volume
two with the next hundred people that
have been on that is wonderful
alright so over time it's just gonna
continue adding up in terms of the
amount of people and highlighting them
and getting them and inspiring children
and young adults to look through that
and be like it's actually about the
impact it's not about what I do it's
about the relationships I build it's
about how I positively change society
all these different things those are
what matter yeah yeah totally I'm I'm
I'm and and this is a huge one I'll
continue on packing and I know we can we
we can spend impact over money if we can
talk about that for the neck for the for
a whole episode just by that itself yeah
and this is so funny because we haven't
even talked about China and that's a
whole episode of itself as well with the
other with your with your immersion into
that technology culture and and
everything that you've been learning so
it seems like there's so many great
episodes that we can that we can do I
wanna I want to at least seriously
seriously impact over money yeah I'm so
serious let's get that top 100 every
like month or every every couple months
published let's get that out there
impacting you don't need that you still
need a little money to make that impact
unfortunately don't you don't you agree
I agree okay so I see money as the tool
but to get to help you accomplish what
you want to accomplish in this world
who's not as the end goal that's the
only difference
do you need money some projects need
just a little money some needle a lot of
money right if you're gonna send people
to Mars that's like an insanely expense
the thing can you get that money well
the money's there and that's one of the
challenges that's like what a lot of
what I do as the head of founders face
is I bring in these entrepreneurs and
try to help them figure out how to get
their ideas funded and also whether
their ideas are truly viable yeah yep
and and that's this that's this
understanding that money is your tool to
help make the impact and to continue
that process over and over again and
funnel the money into the impact funnel
money into Empire yeah once the money
gets funneled into a into a diamond door
into a yacht or into a etc we really
start breaking down the soul it kind of
breaks down yeah I would much rather see
our money put to use in improving
people's lives not just the the point
zero one percent I heard if you throw
enough money at problems they they go
away I actually and new problems give
birth I just I can't I have to drop this
example yeah but ty Lopez tweeted about
how he had a maid in his house after
just working there a couple weeks trip
and fall and sue him for money so you
think money and money will solve my
problems and then you have maids come in
your house and then they and then they
sue you so actually money brings on
problems hilariously enough as well Mo
Money mo problems mo money mo problems
hundred sales like if you have too
little money that's your worst problem I
mean I know people who are really living
the day by day it's not pleasant right
it's it's it's really really difficult
you know and they might have kids that
they have to take care of there might be
a single parent it's even worse yeah
it's really tough if you get above a
certain threshold which is about what is
it like 3040 thousand a year something
like that yeah something like that
depending on how big your family a month
for complete sustainability for yourself
at Li
then you if you have kids or other
relations parents you're taking care of
it can be considerably more but if you
can get above that then at least you can
have a decent quality of life and look
to do more if you're below that I only
feel like yes you should focus on
getting some money because that is your
number one priority like just to survive
and feed yourself and get health care
yep yep so I'm so fascinated by how the
world is going to shape in the next
couple of decades
not only because of this explosion of
creativity as hopefully we can help
foster across the world and how ubi and
AI and how all these things are gonna
impact that process and I really hope
that we don't leave people behind in
like a speciation of the classes and
that's something that I think well it's
getting worse now than it has before
unfortunately in America that's a lot of
reason we have discontent here and it
needs to be addressed I don't think it's
being addressed at all personally right
now I don't think we're doing unpack
that a little more well you know trade
wars aren't gonna solve our problem yeah
trade wars are gonna jack up the prices
and they're gonna be retaliatory so our
goods will be taxed and their goods
everybody gets taxed then one thing
we've learned if you study economics
which I have is that lower truck tariffs
and stimulate trade and trade makes
everybody wealthier it's not our jobs
were lost in the 80s our jobs were lost
by cheaper labor overseas the only way
to compete with that is to lower wages
here to what they are in other parts of
the world and that's not realistic for
an advanced economy now China you think
they stole all our jobs well they're
like losing jobs now the Southeast Asia
where the wages are seeing the wages
have come up a lot in China and now
they're terrified of undergoing what we
just went through so slapping tariffs on
China which isn't even now our problem
it's now Southeast Asia where all these
jobs are going and the jobs will always
migrate like that what we need to do is
educate our workforce and lift them into
higher jobs we need to give them
opportunities we're not giving the
current administration and our
government isn't focused on that
they're just focused on these trade wars
which will make no difference it's just
politics it's just the lip service it's
gonna make no difference to these people
they're not getting those jobs back
those jobs are gone what we need to do
is come to them with a path forward with
education with with like you say
inspiration like you can do this you are
capable of doing I don't care you have a
brain right our brains are incredibly
malleable they're there we can learn new
stuff at any age I've found it doesn't
matter if you're teenager
it doesn't matter if you're 40 or 50 you
can learn new skills you can do it so a
lot of people just don't believe they
can yeah and we have to get out there
with the idea that they can do it and a
path for them to do it that they can see
themselves going at down and becoming a
more successful that is the only way and
a universal basic income right so that
they can get there they can quit their
job they can start retraining themselves
they can have the programs without with
without worrying about their family
starving like or having no medical care
I agree that there's there's really not
enough focus on the retraining process
for advanced careers in the next couple
decades we need more and more attention
on that right you're not gonna be
creating a massive amount of jobs in the
steel industry no matter how you know
that it's gonna be flat at best like
jobs and maybe the augmented reality
industry or maybe the AI ethics our
philosophy or the biotechnology there's
a million area there's no good working
ones every day they're opening up
because new technology is coming and if
we retrain these people in these new
technologies and they can go out there
and they can be experts on electric cars
and do all sorts of different new things
that are coming out they will be in
demand there's a lot actually a lot of
demand for jobs they aren't getting data
scientists like a huge demand now of
jobs like these that they really need
even crafts people like to go people are
valuing more crafts and handmade things
because everything's manufactured and
they'll pay a premium you know we can go
back to training people to be real
crappy wood carvers you know stonemason
they can actually earn a good living but
they need to learn these skills yeah
the
the essence of this question kind of
boils down into how human can we be
about having an honest conversation
about where we should go and I don't
think we have enough global
conversations about where we should go
as a civilization and how we should get
there and so that in its essence is is
so much of our problem it's just not
being able to have open honest
conversations about working your we're
doing it now we're doing it now you're
doing your party but we are definitely
doing your ready to sit down more with
with with people across the world and
and have that conversation and trying I
think about this a lot you know as a
civilization we are actually and this is
a whole nother episode but we are
actually at an inflection point right
now a very critical time yes so all
these new technologies are entering our
societies has an ever-increasing rate
this and these technologies are more
powerful than ever before yes our
legislators our culture is not prepared
it does not understand how these things
will impact us just look at the Facebook
privacy issue right with them sharing
data and how that dramatically impacted
our culture our elections in our
personal lives right because we're
getting fed all this stuff through our
Facebook feed a lot of it is fake a lot
of these the people are selling us stuff
that we may not need and things like
that and we don't have a way of
processing this we also don't know how
they're taking our data in using that to
manipulate the media and manipulate our
desires and things like that
and it's gonna happen we're at the tip
of the iceberg this AI combined with our
personal data is huge it will define
like Amazon and stuff they are starting
they built Pro and Facebook and Google
they're starting to build profiles of
you where they can actually predict what
you're gonna do next
better than you can yeah because these
algorithms like we don't know ourselves
that well are ma you know we're it's
very hard for us to judge who we really
are like a lot of thing we'll tell
ourselves stories about who we are but
it's not what we really end up doing
right it's what we want to believe we
would do but it's not what we actually
do
Facebook did a study which is so telling
they actually took their data and their
algorithm and tried to predict what
people would what people would like you
know on Facebook what ads they would
like what videos they would like what
comments they would like and then they
asked people themselves what they would
like they would show them this and when
people thought about what they would
like and tried to predict what they
would like they did significantly poorer
job at doing this than the algorithm
what does that tell us that even today
with the crude algorithms and and data
we have and it's getting the data is
getting much more granular and the
algorithms are getting much smarter
Facebook can predict what we like better
than we can are see totally scary that's
why this data matters getting control of
our data all these new time what does AI
do in our society we need to have open
conversations about this all around the
world open conversation is how it's
going to be used could be used for great
good yeah and you know changing you know
dealing with climate change dealing with
all these social problems without the
world were tremendous evil and if it's
used for tremendous evil
we were trouble yeah and we got to start
thinking about that now
it's an inflection point like you said
and it's it's the most important
inflection point that we've been at and
it's gonna shape our culture the next
couple of decades and we talk about that
a lot on the show and it's seriously
such a pleasure to have you and talk to
you about all these different things
Steve let's wander you down just like a
quick couple of our simulation questions
how about do you think that we're alone
in the cosmos ah you know probably not
the the odds
I keep hearing I read about this a lot I
read about a lot of things a lot but I
read about the cosmos and it used to
seem like there was a certainty there
were other not just life forms which
almost certainly there are but
intelligent life forms on a level or
even above human beings it seemed like
that was almost a certainty now I've
heard some recent reports that life on
Earth may be much more rare than we
thought it would because of
some chemical combinations and I forget
which which element it was but there's a
certain element that went into making
our planet
that isn't was it potassium or something
like that or phosphorus some something
like on that level I forget the exact
element that is that is very rarely
created in the in the cosmos in the in
the quantity that you would need to have
life on Earth and then I heard other
reports that getting a planet that
orbits a Sun like ours and at just the
right in just the right orbit is also
much more rare than we thought so the
conditions for life on Earth may in fact
be incredibly rare but even with that
there's probably still intelligent life
on earth would we ever connect with that
life or is it so distant so many
billions of year light-years away that
we'll never make contact
maybe now making contact with the other
life could be catastrophic for the human
race if they're anything like us I don't
want to meet it honestly have we been
good to all the animals on our planet
all the lesser species have we been kind
to them are they thriving no they're
dying off by the millions like every you
know every year right species are going
extinct and the others we eat we keep in
like factory farms and kind of torture
and fill with drugs and process and
consume without giving them any quality
of life do we want a species like that
coming to our planet uh god forbid right
that species like us should come to our
planet I don't think they'd be very good
stewards of our planet certainly we have
not evolved yet maybe we can raise our
consciousness and evolve above that but
right now we've been pretty awful so
making contact with another life-form is
is not one of my dreams because it's a
big it's a lottery out there right it's
and and the odds are that they would
have evolved to be pretty aggressive and
may not be kind to us
mm-hmm
part of me wants to still meet of course
we do I'm a curious person I want to
meet these aliens of my lifetime like
even if they annihilate us right
hopefully be friendly and I know an
enlighten us and give us access you know
and make it a world of better tell them
about what we've been through
yeah we would love it there our brother
interesting brothers from another planet
but you know you know you have I'm a
realist
so the dreamer and me absolutely wants
to meet them wants to imagine what
they're like see the world that they've
created
you know merge ourselves what about what
about do you think we're in a computer
simulation you know people say that like
Elon Musk and you know we all saw the
matrix we can't know it's it the same is
asking you know it can God talk to me
until God has talked to you you don't
know right until you figured out that
there's another code that there's some
code running you know below the surface
of everything you don't know I'm not one
to answer that just say that that is the
fundamentals of math and physics of our
world you could if you read you know if
you read string theory and you're into
you know advanced physics was there is
one threat you know there a certain
group of physicists out there who say
we're just information right the whole
world the whole universe is just
information you know I was meeting with
machiya Kaku you know the the physicist
and he does all these great videos and
stuff when we were in Malaysia together
you know giving talks you know we're
talking about this and you know yeah he
was throwing that out there you know
it's you know we have all might be
information yes it and what form to that
information take many different forms
one could be a giant simulation like
your to it like your your show others it
you know it may not be do I personally
this is my question right not whether
there's a simulation I can't know right
you know if I'm in a truly well-designed
simulation I'll never know do I want to
live my life like it's a simulation
the answer's no no I want to live my
life like it has meaning outside of
something that's just pre-programmed
manufactured does
have any impact on like if you're not
real I want to believe you're real so I
don't care I want to live my life and
treat you as if your wheel wheel I don't
want to be otherwise I'm a psychopath
I'm a combination of psychopaths
nihilist right I'm a nihilist because
nothing has any meaning and I it's
like--go path because none of you are
real I could just use you I would argue
and say that it's important to tap into
the fabric of reality and understand
that and there are likely ways to hack
into that and figure it out and then
once you do that even if you figure out
that it is a program have you figured it
out no but okay
but even then once you do tap into it
and start to figure out that oh goodness
there is so but how can you know I think
I can you know actually affect the way
that you act in the world you act in the
world the same no matter which
accordance but it's still fascinating to
know and to try and figure that out
could you act in the world this is a
philosophical question right if you knew
the world was a simulation could you
would it fundamentally changed how you
act in the world your aren't positing
that it does it won't you you say you'll
go back just to how you are sure they're
likely there would be some sort of
desire for explorative change but the
thing is is that you would need to be
able to go back to the moment in time
for example you won't want to drop this
project completely and go to a different
country because then you would never
know what this project would look like
fully developed in the world so the idea
is that if I could do this project while
simultaneously trying to go to a
different country so to be able to maybe
bounce between the two to go between
moments and time like that there's a lot
of different ways to see it view it I do
think it would change some action
potentially I think it would profoundly
a change in me I can't speak for
everybody in the world but if I knew
this world was a simulation and that you
weren't real it would profoundly change
how I act in this world yeah yeah yeah
yeah and when you put it that way no
nobody's real only in real yeah that
would versus prices we are all in a
sense
you know so if I'm at simulation - well
and then if if you're as real as me and
I know how I feel and I know how you
feel and I am a simulation I'm not even
really me that I think I am then that
would have an another effect on me yeah
it would be mind boggling I think I
think just the the sense that you're
Annie and I and everybody is trapped in
their own skulls is enough of an
understanding of like wow I can't leave
my skull that that essence is that you
know David Hume right where you know
empiricism you know you can't know
anything his idea what you know he said
the same thing back you know and oh well
you know a long time ago
he said you know are we all just a dream
you know is are we making every is all
of reality a dream it's the same as
being a simulation right nothing is real
and he tried to imagine he wrote all
these books on imagining what would life
be like you know literally you could
have woken up two seconds ago and
everything you think you've done in your
life is is a fabrication yeah right it's
all been correct you know it's just just
like when you wake up from a dream yeah
and you know the interesting thing is
when you're in a dream you don't you
believe it's real so you so the reason I
know I would act differently in a
simulation and I would in in real life
is because I've done lucid dreaming
right I've been conscious of my dreams
and I know when I'm conscious in my
dreams I act differently yeah
fundamentally act differently yeah it's
totally fun yeah you know you can start
flying and doing all this cool stuff but
you totally change how you your reality
changes and so that's why I know I would
act and I would imagine most people
would act really different if they knew
the world but the beautiful thing is we
live in a world where there people who
are living as if it were a simulation
they believe it there's people who
believe in different gods
there's people believe in all sorts of
different philosophies about the world
and that does impact how they live their
lives at a very core level you
what would you say is the most beautiful
thing in the world Oh
the most beautiful that's a that's a
deep question mmm um did you know the
most beautiful thing in the world is
emotion that we can feel like if you're
drained of emotion I think you're
fundamentally drained of life you know
the essence of life you know if I feel
really it's like there are moments that
come every week for me where I just feel
so happy I just feel so joyous you know
I'm I'm looking at the people I love and
I just feel this dislike there I just
feel so happy and then there are other
times of the week where I feel
frustrated where I'm depressed where I'm
and I'm not manic depressive so but just
normal levels right where I feel anxiety
you know over the future you know all of
these emotions course through us right
and all of them if I didn't have these
emotions if I felt numb then I wouldn't
be human and so emotion to me is the
most beautiful thing yeah the feeling
alive across all the different emotions
it's being able to experience all of
these being able to you know on this
crazy journey were on right this wild
ride going through all of the
rollercoaster of all the different
emotions and and having that color our
lives and make it give it depth and
meaning I think it'd be very hard to
find meaning without emotion I think
when we say meaning we mean how we feel
because meaning is never purely logical
right it's never a plus B equals C you
know it is how we experience our
universe and even the concept of a
meaning is an emotion right when I feel
like you feel what you're doing now is
meaningful that is an emotion you value
above ever
thing else I think that's what's guiding
your life and like I know it I know it's
what's guiding my life yeah the whole
idea of making an impact right what is
an impact right we have to believe in
something right we have to give it your
belief and and and and bestow it with
that it has meaning to you like we could
sort of bring meaning we manufacture our
meaning right we look for things in the
world where we can believe in whether
it's a religion that we follow whether
it's a career we choose whether it's
relationships some people find meaning
in their marriage or in their children
or across a whole array of different
things in our life providing us with
different pieces of meaning that end up
constructing who we are and what we
value and ultimately determining the
decisions we make and that's a bunch of
different feelings that come into us and
yes and that's that's good so what's one
thing that you believe to be true that
nobody else believes to be true well now
you sound like zero to one joking
Peter Thiel isn't my favorite guy he you
know one thing I believe to be true that
nobody else believes in true I you know
I honestly don't think there's anything
I mean nobody else believes to be true I
would be very arrogant
what would think that I had a thought
what about very few that all these
brilliant minds out there didn't have
before me
yeah maybe few people believed to be
true
oh you know
you know I lived my life I try to think
deeply about how to live my life and I'm
always questioning like you do I think
what's real whether the path I'm on it's
the right path went on my core beliefs
and you know certain people settle on a
particular creed or religion or
philosophy you know I can't settle on
one because I feel like it would be if I
just chose one path one strength strict
set of rules or beliefs it would give me
security and comfort in knowing that was
the truth but it would also closed off
so many doors that the one thing I want
to do is explore as many of these paths
as deeply as possible in my lifetime but
at the same time I realized the paradox
is that you can never go too deep if you
don't fully believe in the path that
you're on
so there are certain experiences by
keeping the doors open
I've also automatically shut all the
doors that is a paradox of life that is
one belief I've can't come to you know
some people say oh if you leave all the
doors open you can explore everything
and I'm like yeah but some of those
doors you can only know by just
believing that one thing like how can
you know what it is to truly be a
Christian if you don't totally believe
in Jesus Christ right so if I'm not a
willing to commit a hundred percent and
it to a particular denomination I can
never know what it's like to go down and
truly believe that and at the same time
so every time you close the door you
open the door right and every time you
leave a door open you're shutting
another one and I think that's it that's
that's a good way to put it I think that
our science and entrepreneurship doors
are very very big enough in that yeah
and that's definitely had to close other
doors every time we make everything yeah
and that's that's a one insight that I
had through my own life
variance of wanting being a super
curious person and wanting to try
everything possible during life and and
then coming up against this paradox that
the more I try in a way that more doors
the other doors I'm not going you know I
can never know yeah I'll never know them
yeah yeah yeah I love how we just
scratched the surface at innovation and
creativity at what is the foundation for
an entrepreneur what as these emotional
pillars that can be supported by other
mentors and people around them yeah how
can we work together as a world to
foster entrepreneurship and creativity
how can we prosper together as a world
what is the importance of these types of
big questions and these types of a
meaning of life and all these yeah all
of it in one conversation from the
practical to the esoteric you ask great
questions
I love it you have a good spirit energy
thank you it really makes this flow
really well thank you I think to go from
the Forbes richest 100 do dissimulation
most impactful one yeah yeah let's do it
let's get there we'll get there and
let's let's keep impacting people across
the world everyone thank you for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it Steve thank
you for joining us thank you oh we can
really appreciate it I love it talk
about his book one more time yeah let's
do one more time so make elephants fly
Steve Hoffman and that's about Dreams
your elephant is this huge big dream you
have that seems impossible to get off
the ground right it's an elephant how do
you get an elephant into the air unless
you're Dumbo right it's impossible but
the book is like step by step how do you
do it exactly yeah
step by step making elephants fly get
your idea executed into the world and
also know that that brings you the most
atonement in your life and it will bring
you the most of filament and surround
yourself with other people that also do
do that so everyone thank you for tuning
in if you had a good time please give us
a like and give us a comment below tell
us what you thought about the show share
the content with other people that's
really important you must to subscribe
smash the subscribe button help us out
join us on patreon we have to pay for
our studio with pay for a production of
pay for our food our electricity our
internet to join us to keep us
sustainable keep us doing the show
please we love you so much thank you
thank you Ron Vargas our producing
partner thanks Ron thanks Ron whoo and
at least a sommelier our partner
photographer thank you everyone for
tuning in and we'll catch you guys soon
later
[Music]